maybe this is a bit of a personal
question for me it just out of my own
curiosity but
i've uh talked to ray value a few times
so ray dalio i think
was one of those people that took the
that that journey
uh the the the bitcoin journey give
thoughts about him specifically about
that whole world
and about the journey maybe of others
that are going through the same
process because ray is at least from my
perspective i'm a bit of an outsider
he's
one of the most insightful
and deep thinkers about investment about
finance about
economics in general actually about life
so it's interesting to see him go on
that journey
do you have something to comment about
rey or just those kinds of people in
general
so if we look at um what i'll just
consider the legends of wall street in
general yeah right
um there's no denying that they're
incredibly intelligent uh there's no
denying that
actually especially in the hedge fund
world they're some of the most
open-minded
people uh in terms of they're willing to
change their mind when they get new
information
uh there's no doubt that they are
historians in the sense of having
studied financial markets and cycles
over time
and also one of the things that i really
respect about all those guys is
almost all of them are willing to put
ideas out
via various writings that they do and
accept the public criticism right
whether it's howard marx ray or others
they will put this stuff out in public
and uh sure there's a lot of people who
are supportive and kind of are part of a
fan base if you will
but there's a lot of people who also
think that sometimes they say stupid
things
and so putting that out takes kind of
courage right um
i think rey is actually the most
fascinating though out of all of these
kind of legends of wall street in that
um he understands debt cycles he
understands currencies
he for a while now has been all over
and famously said you know cash's trash
uh investable assets right he just
he kind of like just knew all of it and
for a long time bitcoin has said ray
you understand the bitcoin argument
you're just missing the last part which
is bitcoin's the solution
right and so he was gold and some other
ideas but
i think that he's a perfect example of
when you are
part of uh the establishment people
view you in a very static way as uh the
leader of
a part of establishment but whether it's
bill gates ray dalio or somebody else
each one of these people were innovators
and challengers to a system they were
upstarts at one point
and so it's kind of this idea that like
if you live long enough you eventually
become the man
right and so you know gates is a good
example right
warren buffett is a good example ray
dalio is a good example et cetera and so
uh you have to give credit i think to
dalio in the sense of
he kept an open mind about all of this
and more so than many of his peers
has continued to do the work and come
around to this idea
uh and now i don't want to know if i
wanted to say that he's a bitcoin
proponent
as much as he believes it is one of you
know a
portion of assets that can be a solution
and so to me
when you start to convince those types
of people when it's you know paul tudor
jones a stanley druckenmiller
ray dalio uh howard mark's now even
writing about it saying hey
you know i was anti bitcoin i didn't put
a ton of intellectual
rigor into it but thank god my son
bought a bunch of our family right
and uh and kind of we've had exposure to
it
i think what it does is more than
anything it's not going to convince
somebody to go and
you know take it seriously or go ahead
and make an allocation
it reduces career risk and so if all of
a sudden when
paul tudor jones and stanley drackey
miller come out and say hey i own
bitcoin
and here's why every other investor on
wall street now can say to an investment
committee
well it's good enough for paul tudor
jones it's good enough for stanley
trucken miller
and so i think that it's very
interesting because rey doesn't just
represent
wall street i think ray in some weird
way represents this like
macro economic investor and so some of
those are in hedge funds and some of
those
uh people would be like cios at
organizations some of them would be at
corporations and some of them are just
kind of retail investors
and so you can see this kind of
inflection point
throughout the adoption of bitcoin right
there was infrastructure that got built
okay that kind of led to more adoption
there was uh certain
individuals right usually they were kind
of technology oriented
entrepreneurial billionaires they would
buy it and come out and say it okay that
led to inflection
points uh you started to have some of
these
kind of wall street legends come out
sort of financial institutions
started now you're seeing corporations
start to do it right
eventually there's gonna be a central
bank that does it and so you kind of
walk through that line and what you
understand it's like it's the same thing
every time it's just somebody new
right that that path right that
bitcoiners journey if you will
and i think that that is almost the
beauty
of it is uh if you short circuit the
journey
it's almost like somebody doesn't
appreciate it right if you take let's
say somebody who's a young kid and you
just give them a bunch of money and they
didn't have to work hard for it
they don't really appreciate it and uh
ray
ray actually has the book principles
right and he talks about the hero's
journey so
he's like living in some sense in terms
of
you know thinking about digital currency
in general like
digital finance
you